[Music]
gentlemen is the final rose tonight
look the only choice she's got she's not
gonna move to a farm with those heels
she's kissed him Oh with a chance she's
a walking venereal disease chase
seeing an overdrawn balance in your
daily checking yeah my mortgage payment
tripled I disclosed a possibility of a
rate hike during your refi do you
remember that everyone on the ground now
the three men walked off 1.6 million
dollars light choreographed it like a
tom acke on the line right into prison
they didn't get cool semtex steel has
frozen all pension payments thinking of
robbing a bank I'm thinking about buying
a Ferrari I just not have to buy the
Knicks could we pray about huh
Williamsburg savings will manage the
liquidation of the fund these bank
practically destroyed this country and
nothing ever happened to them I want to
write the book let's go get our money
back
yeah you pick a clapper what's on the
pension right that's all I'm gonna do
what are we gonna wait give it to
charity
it's time for a practice run we'll be
right back
I don't want to stay in the car it's hot
in here hello Wow gotta get some chicken
thighs breasts are better than thighs
don't you think never
has anybody walked off with a whole pork
line jump into Fosters we hope you think
I am hey what's going on in the world
anymore hide what your date to Cindy
she's looking like a Colombian drug mule
we're gonna need from baseball hell you
think you five-o we're practically a tow
now on you can only get by next how do
you work a lot buttons to touch brain
I'm groping it all over the Urban's
reminds me at a time we went arena we
ate like kings working Priscilla
ladies and gentleman
Oh Oh what are you chasing me for I'll
make it easy this is not an admission of
guilt
I'm just tired that Brody ready for duty
do you just look at my boobs
ah you should look at my face I'm trying
but it's so close to your boobs ha this
is the guy